hallo Leute und Willkommen zu vlogmas
Tag 6 einen wunderschönen Nikolaus Tag
wünsche ich euch aber ihr fragt euch
sicher wie ich in diese Situation
gekommen
bin alles hat beim Frühstück
angefangen Bo okay die Auswahl ist auch
einfach viel zu groß guck malog gleich
morgens K Essen
noodles das sieht koreanisch aus das
sind einfach die
süßkartoffelnudel ne ja oh mein Gott die
hab auch schon schuka natürlich darf in
Italien nicht fehlen
Schinken
Gemüsesalat frisches Obst geil du machst
dir jetzt ein Obstsalat die hatten da
eine kleine eigene Bäckerei oh mein Gott
das ist genau das was ich mir
vorgestellt habe das ist das
perfekte Hammer auch Glas was ist das ke
Ahnung croisson sieht so krass aus die
haben so diese perfekten croissons für
die man in Berlin ansteht dieses
Frühstück war wirklich das krasseste
Hotelfrühstück was ich jemals gesehen
habe und ich war mit Naomi in einem 400
€ rit Karten Frühstück und dieses
Frühstück war besser als das und dann
sind wir auf Mission gegangen denn ich
brauchte einen Badeanzug und Timo eine
Badehose ich wollte euch gerade die
Poller zeigen von unserem Hotel die sind
gerade hochgefahren damit ja auch
wirklich keiner hier reinkommt der nicht
hier
reingehört mega coole Straßenbahn im
Dezember Schwimmsachen finden das das
ist schon zum Scheitern verurteilt
neintim bei allem immer viel positiver
als ich aber so ist das in ein guten
Beziehung ne plus und minus Outfit
Check wir sind in der Stadt des Designs
und der Mode und ich schreie PIP lang
aber die Gebäude sind auch alle übelst
geil hier
ne wow das sieht toll aus diese
Sehenswürdigkeit habe ich noch nie
gesehen sieht echt heftiger
aus ich war ja ich war ja in Las Vegas
ne das ist genau das was Las Vegas
versucht zu sein in manchen Sachen wenn
sie so bagio und sowas machen oder dann
gab's so eine Mall mit so einer Decke
das ist genau das was sie machen wollen
aber das ist der real
deal wenn du dir noch vorschst wie alt
das ist auch alleine Boden derod wie
geil der Boden
aussieht nennt man das diesen kleinen
Mosaik Stil ja Mosaik ja die ganzen
Designer hier sind alle vertreten ne
fendy Louis
V Swarowski s den kaufen ja ich frage
mich nur warum steht da kein
Preis ach
doch ja gut wir wir gehen mal bei H&M
weiter gucken ein Outfit
10k
sk okay Leute derowski Store h
anders dieses Zeichen gibt mir PTSD von
dem Adventskalender Unboxing Video ich
liebeski vor allem deren Adventskalender
jetzt kommen wir auf so ein fetten Plaza
rechts nicht nach links gucken nicht
linksck wartete und jetzt kannst du dich
umdrehen und
gucken
heftig oder hast du deine Wertsachen bei
dir solche Plätze sind glaube ich immer
Dreh und Angt für für die TH meine
Tasche ist schon
auf tasum ich mit offener Tasche fertig
krass oder guck mal das schönheitsding
an Schönheit da hinten kommen auch schon
zu unserer Destination ich weiß nicht ob
du schon gesehen hast da sind wir wieder
bei unserer wir müssen an Tiffany und Co
vorbei beim teuren Schmuck um die
H& auch so kleine Weihnachtsstände
ne da sind wir da ist der Laden unserer
Begierde sehr leer werden wir aber
niemals finden sage ich dir leider wie
es ist im Winter ein Badeanzug bei hm
ist glaube ich absolut das letzte was
wir finden ja da können die loser gleich
wieder nach Hause gehen wir haben
gefragt gibt's kein bei H&M because not
the season so
f owski verfolgt mich nach ein bisschen
Suchen haben wir einen Sportladen und
einen Badanzug gefunden moin Leute zeig
was wir bekommen haben da ist die
Ausbeute da ist sie ein Badeanzug
Badehose
Skimaske
und
was
so wir sind jetzt quasi in einem kleinen
Imbis drin kleinen Snack essen wir eine
Spaghetti Carbonara Timo du musst es vor
der Kamera jetzt einmal probieren okay
wir gehen rein so eine einfache easy
imbisonar aber es schmeckt auf jeden
Fall schon Taus mal hochwertiger als
alles was du ansatzweise in Deutschland
für so in der Range
kriegst für so eine
imbisnudel boah deine sind ja heftig das
kam in Z Minuten 10 Minuten Zeit
deswegen essen wir haben jetzt wirklich
in 10 Minuten unsere Nudeln runter
gehauen gehen kurz noch mal zurück zum
Hotelzimmer dann geht's schon zum Pop-Up
Store ich stehe hier gerade live vor dem
jeppuda Pop-Up Store in Mailand und wie
es da drin aussieht zeige ich euch jetzt
doch zuerst brauchen wir eine
Erfrischung und zwar von diesem
wunderbaren ja was ist das ist so ein
Fahrrad eigentlich so ein Kaffeewagen
oder das ist vielleicht so ein typisch
italienisches Ding was wir nicht kennen
hier gibt es the bubble double da ist
eigentlich der wunderbare Cleanser drin
den ihr schön schaumig auf euer Gesicht
auftragen könnt doch jetzt kann man
daraus trinken ich find es ein bisschen
komisch weil da sonst ein Reinigungszeug
drin ist aber ich denke mal sie haben es
entweder gut ausgewaschen oder da war
noch nie Reinigungszeug drin
Prost mein Hirn denkt das ist
Reinigung ich habe schon gehört das soll
so koreanischer Tee sein aber ich kann
einfach nur daran denken dass es the
bubble double ist wenn ich überlegen
müsste wie Bubble double vielleicht
schmeckt würde ich genau das sagen da
hinten die Gründerin von jeppoda ich
hoffe sie noch für ein Interview zu
kriegen lass uns mal unbedingt noch das
Essen testen Timo kannst du das
[Musik]
abfeln tschüss ne war nett bei euch ihr
glaubt nicht was hier drin ist hier ist
eigentlich the sex drin eine mattierende
brightening Gesichtsmaske die man sich
mit einem Pinsel auftragen kann aber
heute ist da kimbab drin wer hier
marketingmäßig drauf gekommen ist
Beförderung oder ich liebe
Kim schmeckt original wie Kim schmeckt
anders alsi so als nächstes tragen wir
uns den them auf da nehmt ihr dann
einfach das vegane toboki was da drin
ist und tragt euch das VI ein bisschen
auf die Lippen könt ihr alles damit
machen ist wirklich einfach to
drin voll gut als dritten
Ganges
Augenpads die zeige ich euch ganz kurz
ah ja diese Augenpads sind sehr
hydrierend ne für müde Augen mach den
wach mach die einfach so drauf morgens
und dann könnt ihr es
essen jetzt habe ich mich gestärkt und
wir gehen mal
[Musik]
rein
ich bin hier live mit der Gründerin von
jepuda du hast es zusammen mit deinem
Partner gegründet jetzt Mann ja genau
genau und erzähl mir doch mal so ein
bisschen das Konzept von dem Store ja
viele von unseren Kundinnen die mögen
natürlich besonders gerne unsere Routine
und deshalb haben wir hier auch noch mal
das ein bisschen aufgegriffen dass man
die Routine noch besser entdecken kann
ja ich sehe schon ja hier hast du diesen
Weg genau wir haben hier so eine
routinenline sozusagen da kann man alle
einzelnen Produkte für jeden einzelnen
step der Routine auch ausprobieren es
gibt auch so eine kleine Beschreibung
dazu und wir haben da hinten auch noch
ein Skin Analyzer so dass jeder auch
noch ausprobieren kann okay wie geht's
gerade meiner Haut was hat die für
Bedürfnisse und dann seine Routine
darauf abstimmen kann das haben wir doch
auch in Soul schon gemacht gen
skinanalyse ich weiß nicht ob noch dran
erinner
und ihr habt eine fotobo ja ja ja so ein
bisschen das zweite Motto also neben
Routine war natürlich so ein bisschen
das Motto Soul nach Mailand zu bringen
und ja deshal haben wir natürlich auch
eine koreanische fotoost die durfte
natürlich nicht vi die will ich jetzt
unbedingt
[Musik]
anschauen warte wir brauchen hier
meineorit okay
[Musik]
die
Stimme hen
love cool was für eine coole Fotobox so
ein bisschen wie dieser Trend wo man
gerade so die Kamera an die Decke macht
und dann diese Danzinger
macht bin sehr zufrieden mit meinem Bild
vielen
Dank tschüss tchüss Timo wir bleiben
jetzt hier wir müssen ein paar Produkte
verkaufen so wir haben jetzt noch ein
Auftrag wir müssen zurück zum Hotel und
schwimmen gehen aber ich wollte euch
noch vorher zeigen wie schön der Popup
Store von draußen aussieht wenn ihr bis
jetzt noch nicht in Weihnachtsstimmung W
spätestens
jetzt wir gehen jetzt schwimmen
oh shit Leute ich habe die nicht
anprobiert aber passt einmal noch mal
Präsentation sieht aber lit aus ich
dachte irwi der wird gar nicht hier
stehen aber der sieht voll cool aus
skeptisch aber ich find richtig gut aus
ich kan ich habe sofort ich dachte so
diese Farben das sieht halt so wei du du
h halt ein Auge
dafür ist halt so Milan Milan macht's
möglich schaut ihn euch an wie er hier
mit seinem Bademantel
stolziert richtig auf secret Mission
jetzt so nach 5 Tagen vlogmas merke ich
die ersten Anzeichen von Schwäche und da
kommt
eral warm e ist es ge krank ich bin eine
Meerjungfrau ich kann dir meine Beine
nicht zeigen weil da gerade eine Flosse
ist ich
zeig danach hatten wir ein Korean food
Dinner date was wir nicht erwartet haben
wir sind zum fine dining Korean gegangen
also wir hatten uns ein bisschen
eingestellt auf Korean Barbecue die
klassischen street food Sachen aber nein
das war alles so bisschen sehr schick
trotzdem war es ein mega cooler Tag und
jetzt liege ich hier mit full face
Make-up und mein Bademantel weil ich zu
faul bin um mich abzuschminken Spaß ich
ich mache das jetzt wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder ne zu Tag Nummer 7 so
lange haben wir schon ein morgen haben
wir eine Woche durchgezogen yay